>> Laura: WELCOME BACK.
THE LITTLE WOLF AND THE BLACK
DRESSES.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF MY BONUS
ANGLE.
FIRST, I WAS REMISS ON FRIDAY
BECAUSE I DID NOT MENTION THE
PART OF THAT MICHAEL WOLF'S
IT'S A SMALL ANECDOTE THAT
CLAIMED AT THE FUNERAL OF FORMER
FOX NEWS CHAIRMAN ROGER AILES
FABRICATED.
IT NEVER HAPPENED.
MEAN?
TOO MUCH IF AT ALL AT THE
FUNERAL.
BUT WOLFF DIDN'T CARE.
HE WANTED TO ADVANCE HIS RICKETY
ANTI-TRUMP AGENDA, THE FACTS BE.
NO I DIDN'T BUY THE STUPID BOOK,
I BORROWED SOMEONE ELSE'S.
SECOND, THE GOLDEN GLOBES, FOR
ONCE I WASN'T IN THE SLIGHTEST
ANNOYED WHEN MY CABLE WENT OUT
WORKS.
I WAS BLISSFULLY UNAWARE OF THAT
#TimesUp AND BLACK DRESS
DECORATIONS BY WOMEN WHO FOR THE
SAME WOMEN WHO WERE MOSTLY
SILENT DURING HARVEY WEINSTEIN'S
RAM OF SEXUAL TERROR.
WATCHING A BUNCH OF
EMOTING AND CONJURED UP EMPATHY
ISN'T EXACTLY MY IDEA OF A FUN
SUNDAY NIGHT.
THAT #TimesUp GROUP ANNOUNCED
BEFORE THE SHOW THEY WOULD ALL
BE WEARING BLACK TO PROTESTANT
MEN WHO HARASS WOMEN.
THERE WASN'T MUCH OF A MENTION
OF WOMEN WHO HARASSED MEN AS I
RECALL.
INDUSTRY AFRAID TO EXPRESS VIEWS
THAT MAY BE REMOTELY
CONSERVATIVE, NOW THEY ARE
AFRAID TO DRESS THE WAY THEY
WANT TO ADDRESS.
AND THE COLOR THEY WANT TO WEAR.
HOW IS IT ANY LESS DEMEANING AND
DOMINEERING FOR A BUNCH OF
POWERFUL WOMEN TO TELL OTHER
WOMEN WHAT TO WEAR THAN IT IS
AS PER RESULTING IN SOME
TANGIBLE CHANGE FOR THE
FARMWORKERS AND THE HOSPITALITY
WORKERS, I'LL LET ROSE McGOWAN
COMMIT THE ACTRESS LARGELY
RESPONSIBLE SUM IT UP.
SHE SAID IF THAT'S A BAND-AID TO
MAKE YOURSELF FEEL BETTER ABOUT
WHAT YOU HAVE ALL KNOWN ABOUT
AND EVENT SILENT WITNESSES TO
AND PARTICIPANTS IN THAT SILENCE
AND NO, I DON'T FORGIVE.
NOW WASHINGTON IS TAKING UP THAT
HAVE ANNOUNCED THAT THEY ARE
GOING TO BE WEARING BLACK IN
SUPPORT OF #TimesUp AT THE
STATE OF THE UNION.
PRESIDENT TRUMP, I WOULDN'T.
MOST EVERY MOMENT BE
OVERSHADOWED BY PROTEST?
AND THEN THERE'S OPRAH WINFREY,
I HAD A FIVE HOUR DELAY COMING
BACK FROM THE GAME ON MONDAY
NIGHT.
IT WAS NICELY WRITTEN, AND WELL
DELIVERED HER TALK AT THE
GOLDEN GLOBES.
IT WAS ALSO PURELY POLITICAL.
ARE WE TO BELIEVE THAT SHEET
LIKE MERYL STREEP AND THEY ALL
THE OTHER ACTRESSES AND SO FORTH
JUST HAD THAT THEIR EPIPHANIES
ABOUT HARVEY WEINSTEIN, KEVIN
SPACEY, AND ALL THE REST OF THEM
IN HOLLYWOOD?
OPRAH HAS SPOKE COMPELLINGLY
MEGA
MEGAPHONE IN THE MEDIA FOR
POSITIONS OF POWER FOR YEARS.
WHAT TOOK THEM SO LONG?
HERE'S MY ANGLE ON THIS.
SINCE THAT RUSSIA COLLUSION
NARRATIVE ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT TRUMP HASN'T
MATERIALIZED AND ALL OF THESE
PREDICTIONS ABOUT THE
TRUMP-APOCALYPSE HASN'T COME
THROUGH, THE LEFT IS DESPERATELY
SCRAMBLING TO ANYTHING TO HOLD
ONTO, ANYTHING TO GIVE THEM HOPE
ONTO, ANYTHING TO GIVE THEM HOP
HOPE.
SO IT'S OPRAH, SHE IS THEIR
LIFELINE.
SHE SHOULD THROW HER HAT IN THE
RING, WHY NOT?
THE PRESIDENT FEELS THE SAME.
>> President Trump: SHE WOULD
BE A LOT OF FUN, I KNOW HER VERY
POLITICS HER LAST WEEK AND SHE
HAD TO DONALD TRUMP AND MY
SHE'S GOING TO RUN.
IS FROM HOSTING A TALK SHOW.
HER THE STANDING O ON SUNDAY
NIGHT.
IF SHE DIDN'T RUN, I PREDICT
SHE'S GOING TO HAVE A LOT MORE
RESPECT FOR JUST HOW HARD IT WAS
FOR DONALD TRUMP, A TOTAL
OUTSIDER TO POLITICS TO HAVE
RUN, BEATEN ALL THOSE
REPUBLICANS, BEATEN THE OBAMA'S,
BEATEN THE CLINTONS, BEATEN
HOLLYWOOD AND WHEN IT ALL.
OPRAH WINFREY VERSUS WHO?